well there's so much news going on right
now it's hard to keep up but we think
something really significant has just
happened in the state of California the
Attorney General there Xavier Becerra
just sent a warning to employers in his
state he said this yesterday he said
defy the federal government where he
will face punishment federal immigration
authorities reportedly are planning a
crackdown in California which has more
illegal aliens in any other state in
response to that Becerra held a press
conference in which he threatened
Californians with prosecution and heavy
fines if they dare to collaborate with
their government in any way to help
enforce this country's borders we want
to repeat that and let it sink in for a
second the country's biggest state is
punishing its citizens for following
federal law well it's not just Craven
politics it's a threat to the basic
integrity of the United States how basic
well there's a famous Supreme Court
decision called McCulloch versus
Maryland in that case the court held
that because the federal government is
supreme to the States it is
unconstitutional for the states to
sabotage valid actions of the federal
government that case was decided in 1819
it's been settled law for almost 200
years a lot of things we take for
granted rests on that case it's easily
one of the most important Supreme Court
decisions in our history if you ignore
it the u.s. immediately falls apart
that's not an overstatement think about
it if you followed by Sara's lead and
any state could simply nullify any
federal law didn't like what would
happen that means not just immigration
laws by the way that means tax laws that
means interstate commerce foreign trade
abortion narcotics human trafficking
guns you name it think of a law what
would happen well the country would
immediately descend into uncover nerble
chaos keep it in mind and this would be
relevant every state also maintains its
own heavily armed National Guard
disaster and it's not a theoretical
disaster by the way it actually happened
to us once liberals used to worry about
things like this you remember the media
hyperventilating pretty recently because
Nevada rancher cliven Bundy tried to
defy federal land use law out west you
saw them cheer as an obscure county
clerk in Kentucky called Kim Davis went
to jail for refusing to grant gay
marriage licenses a couple years ago
those cases were nothing
compared to this in scale or
significance the chief law enforcement
officer of the country's largest state
has essentially declared independence
from the rest of America and he's
ordered his citizens to secede with him
we fought a civil war over this very
question 150 years ago Democrats lost by
the way keep in mind that California is
challenging the integrity of the Union
not in order to help its citizens but on
behalf of a foreign population that has
no right to be here in the first place
we've had a lot of people on this
program lately to talk about daca in
illegal immigration
we've asked every one of them the same
question which is the only question that
actually matters how does any of this
help American citizens every night we
ask that question so far we've not yet
received a single coherent answer not
one do you think that you have an
obligation to represent American
citizens first above people who are here
illegally I've represented my citizens
very well Thank You Tucker everyone that
what how about in each specific case we
say if you're an immigrant here really
simple prove that you're producing more
than you consume would you be for
applying that standard I'm for the
American people I'm for Republicans
Democrats coming together you're not
answer every parent in America worries
about the cost
now taxpayers in New Jersey was
subsidizing the cost for illegal aliens
why does that help them why does that
help citizens of New Jersey didn't you
say she said you should throw them all
out I mean could you really be
suggesting that we're gonna take a half
a million people in our state and deport
them could you be suggesting that we're
not going to you don't have a nation
they don't have an answer because they
don't care what the answer is because
helping Americans is not the point the
illegal immigration makes them feel like
good people it makes their donors much
richer and of course and this is the
core point it ensures their re-election
for ever and ever
now it's destroying the country we grew
up in but whatever all they see is
upside Rebecca Kaplan is an Oakland City
Councilwoman she joins us tonight
Rebecca thanks for coming on so here you
have the Attorney General of the state
of California threatened to prosecute
citizens for a
federal law doesn't that sound like
something that happens in Mexico not the
United States well I think your point
about the importance of protecting our
citizens in our community is really well
taken and the reason I introduced the
resolution that the Oakland City Council
passed to have our police not work on
immigration raids is because we have
problems of real crime in our community
and diverting our scarce police
resources away from fighting violence
away from fighting serious crime in
order to participate in immigration
raids
okay undermines the safety of the
community that is we're talking past
each other though with respect so what
the new news here is that you're
Attorney General Xavier Becerra has said
he will prosecute Californians employers
who follow federal law and I'm asking
whatever you think about immigration
illegal or otherwise that's the
beginning of chaos can you see that well
depending on how it's used it could be
however we've heard some serious cases
of employers hiring undocumented
immigrants and then refusing to pay them
and then threatening to call ice if they
complain about knocking that's not a
tool to break their long well that's one
of the reasons and I think that's a real
concern actually we agree on that that's
one of the reasons I'm against Italy
Confederation is because it exploits
workers of all kinds and that's kind of
the point and I'm sure that's why your
donors are for it because they benefit
but that's not what the Attorney General
of your state said he said if you follow
immigration law federal immigration law
we will prosecute you and I don't think
you have to be crazy to imagine how
other states might decide well okay
we're gonna prosecute our citizens for
following federal tax law or abortion
law or interstate commerce statutes do
you see why this could result pretty
quickly and like I don't know a civil
war well I certainly respect your
concern that could be abused what I'm
saying is we haven't seen yet any cases
brought there could be cases where it is
justified what we passed in Oakland is
not an obligation on private citizens or
private companies it's a direction to
our own taxpayer funded law enforcement
right I get one
not a million a million times and we
could have it now but this just seems
much bigger to me and it is your state
and he's a fellow Democrat and he's
someone with his eyes in the White House
he's nationally prominent he's certainly
well known and it just seems like he
stepped over a line where he's not
really behaving as Attorney General's
typically do he's declaring independence
from the rest of the country doesn't
that worry you well certainly I worry
when law enforcement steps over the line
and that's why we in Oakland were so
concerned when ice agents came in tore
apart a family in West Oakland sent a
young man for deportation who was not
accused of any crime and caused great
harm to our community
okay we may not I agree to this extent
there are lots of federal laws that I
don't like I don't like to see them
enforced because I don't like them
however I don't challenge the legitimacy
of the law of federal law enforcement of
the Congress of the United States
because that would result in Civil War
and anarchy and that's exactly what your
Attorney General just did and so I'm
giving you an opportunity right now to
say to him don't do this don't secede
from the rest of the United States from
the country and do this it's it's a it's
a crazy thing to do do you do you not
agree well I think there's very much
concern in our community about the
overreach of ice and their explicit
targeting duties I'm being respectful I
think you're a smart person and I think
this is bigger than whether a family in
Oakland was hassled by ice this has to
do with the staying together of the
fifty United States do you think it's
okay if tomorrow the Attorney General of
Idaho said we're not respecting federal
gun law and we're gonna allow people to
buy fully automatic weapons how about
hand grenades and maybe some of them
will get into the state of California
how would you feel about that oh I'm
very concerned about the flood of
illegal guns into California a robot
come on come on
it's like whatever I say you're giving
me the bumper sticker but be a human
being with me this seems like a huge
Christmas overreach absolutely I worry
about Long Xavier Becerra your chief law
enforcement official in the biggest
state in the Union saying I'm gonna
prosecute you for following American law
you don't think that's huge
well I think that there could be a case
that would be problematic but I'm saying
I have seen him do that what I have seen
is the head of ice target oh man
based on these bridges hey I have a
question for you you live in the Bible
right you've talked about don't don't
give me the Bible thing no I'm not here
to talk about my religious beliefs I'm
here to talk about the integrity of the
Republic I don't think I'm overstating
and I'm not givin to hysteria but this
seems like a really big thing and you're
ignoring it and I don't think you should
I think that's a big mistake we're out
of time Rebecca but I appreciate your
coming on even if you refuse to answer a
single question thank you